[Music]
this great big story is made possible by
lexus experience amazing
[Music]
cotton candy
who knew sugar and air could taste so
sweet
well a guy named james morrison an
amateur inventor whose occupation and
taste buds didn't exactly align
he was a dentist
and during his lifetime james even
became the president of the tennessee
dental association don't forget to floss
but he was also a confectionary
enthusiast with a passion for culinary
advancement he paired with john c
walthan an old friend and fellow
confectioner together the two designed
and co-patented what they called the
electronic candy machine the device
rapidly spun and melted sugar through
small holes until it was fluffy and
nearly 70 percent air they called the
new treat fairy floss they introduced
their product at the 1904 world's fair
selling it in small wooden boxes for 25
cents each
that's about six dollars today fairy
floss was a huge success
in six months they sold over 68 000
boxes grossing in today's money around
440 000
but despite the success of the sugar
spun business
morrison returned to his day job as a
dentist so next time the dentist tells
you you're eating too many sugary treats
well blame him
there's this amazing picture of my
co-worker it's him reading a ninja
turtles book lying next to a super
soaker
when the super soaker came out it was a
game changer the slogan wetter is better
was essentially a mantra for kids during
summer break
so when i went to atlanta to interview
the guy responsible for all that i had
to show him the photo
that's funny
lonnie johnson invented the super soaker
back in 1982
but that is not his only invention
well i have over 100 patents
everything from the nerf gun to a
thermoelectric energy converter he also
worked on nasa's galileo mission to
jupiter and alongside the us military
the first super soaker actually i made
in my shop in my basement in the
evenings when i would come home from
work and at the time i was actually
working on the stealth bomber program
back when it was highly classified and i
actually couldn't even tell my wife what
i was working on during the daytime it
was that that top secret the original
name for the super soaker was the
drencher we ran into a challenge
regarding the name because another
inventor claimed it so we changed the
name to super soaker just to avoid
having to to deal with that super soaker
is definitely a way better name
when he started lonnie wasn't trying to
create a toy for kids i was working on a
new type of heat pump that would use
water as a working fluid instead of
freon
and i was experimenting with some
nozzles that i machined
and i shot a stream of water across the
bathroom and i thought she's maybe i
should put this hard side stuff aside
and work on something fun like a water
gun
it still works and this brings me back
to a previous point lonnie johnson is a
super genius scientist
this is his lab
and this is what he's working on now
right now working on advanced maverick
technology my goal is to develop a
battery that will store about three
times the energy of a lithium-ion
battery in comparison the super soaker
might not seem as hard science
but it was still a really really
important invention
[Music]
they dance they flail they're a big
wacky and awkward way to get your
attention but did you know these tall
boys debuted at the 1996 olympics as art
[Music]
meet peter minshall a prominent
caribbean artist known in trinidad as
the creator of larger-than-life dancing
puppets created for carnival his work
made its way to a book called caribbean
festival arts and that book made its way
to a man a man on the steering committee
of the olympics
peter was commissioned to help create an
unforgettable opening for the 1996
olympic games in atlanta in a moment
nothing short of pure genius peter
returned to his roots by sketching a
puppet-like structure but this time he
turned it into an inflatable air man
that would move and dance just like his
manned puppets for this he had to call
in another artist darone gazette an
engineer who happened to be obsessed
with anything inflatable between both
men they were able to accomplish the
seemingly impossible 60-foot inflatable
two-legged dancing men the tall boys
were nothing short of a success after
they graced the olympics gazette got a
patent and licensed the design to
various advertisers now they're
everywhere use car lots crop fields
shopping centers you name it
so the next time you see a big
ridiculous inflated tall boy waving at
you in the distance just imagine you're
in the caribbean dancing along to the
drum beat
[Music]
there is a wise old japanese saying
the nail that sticks out gets hammered
down
well down in tokyo there's one nail that
sticks out just about as far as you can
imagine an inventor known across the
country a mad genius with a staggering
number of patents
[Music]
that includes a wig for self-defense
meet yushiro nakamatsu you may notice
his name is spelled nakamats
he dropped the letter u because he says
an eight-letter name is easier to
remember but he still wants you to
pronounce it
you got it duck
dr nakamatsu's quirky inventions brought
him worldwide recognition
inventions like the pyeongpyong boots
with springs that put an extra bounce in
your step
there's dr nakamatsu cerebrox
it looks like a lazy boy but the doc
says the darn thing enhances brain power
then there's the gold golf putter that
pinks
when you strike the ball
would you look at that
you know you've made it when the streets
are named after you but make no mistake
dr nakamatsu's inventions aren't all
noisy golf clubs and bouncy shoes
he claims to have invented the floppy
disk
that's right
that floppy disk
retractable landing gear
a widely used kerosene pump
and even the digital watch
to maintain his hyper creativity dr
nakamatsu keeps his mind and body in
shape
that lightweight inventor thomas edison
said
genius is one percent inspiration and 99
perspiration
is that your secret dr nakamatsu
you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nakamatsu saw the cancer as an
opportunity
it was his greatest challenge to invent
his way out of an impossible corner
he developed his own personal cancer
treatment
this includes a meticulously documented
diet
and a new invention to fight the cancer
he calls the gangan robot
the doctors gave him one year to live
that
was five years ago
[Music]
m
[Music]
you